photons are the packets of energy our
eyes detect to see the world around us
and in the bizarre world of quantum
mechanics photons are at the very heart
of magnetism plunging down to the
subatomic level we can see how atoms are
made up of a nucleus surrounded by a
cloud of electrons think about the
structure of an atom there's a positive
charge to the nucleus and then the
electrons have a negative charge these
two attract each other to explain this
attraction quantum physicists think that
both protons and electrons spit out
short-lived bursts of photons oppositely
charged particles absorb each other's
light
and this draws the particles together
this attractive force is known as
electromagnetism atoms themselves would
not hold together if it weren't for
electromagnetic forces electromagnetism
also causes atoms to stick together
to create the molecules that form us and
everything around us electromagnetism is
responsible for the very structure of
our matter atoms holding together
molecular bonds in our bodies those are
bound together by electromagnetic
interactions and therefore they're bound
together by light
the universe without electromagnetism
would come apart at the seams
if electromagnetism was turned off
matter would dissolve
everything would just move fall apart
I could probably with my superhuman
strength hold myself together but the
rest of you are doing
electromagnetism not only holds
everything together it makes things feel
solid
when you touch something that's the
electromagnetic force as well we have
electrons and there are atoms and they
repel each other and when you try to
touch something those forces keep you
from actually physically touching it
the reason I don't fall through the
floor is not that the forest but to be
solid most of the floor is empty space
it's the electric forces of the atoms in
the floor against the electric forces of
the atoms in my body that hold me up
just those little forces of those few
atoms are enough to hold me up against
the entire gravitational force of the
earth electromagnetism rules